muss zuerst mal Herrn Vogel Fragen auf
der Skala von 0 bis 10
als wie gerecht empfinden Sie unser
Steuersystem
also ich jede Steuersystem ist nicht
perfekt aber ich empfinde es im
Grundsatz als gerecht wenn wir uns zum
Beispiel mal die die Einkommensteuer
anschauen dann sieht man
starke Schultern tragen mehr als
schwache zum Beispiel die oberen zehn
Prozent tragen zu Hälfte zum
einkommensteueraufkommen bei wie viel
aber deutlich Rechte Stunde
Grundverteilung was ich unfair finde ist
dass wir klein und mittlere Einkommen
internationalen Vergleich extrem hoch
belasten das halte ich für ein echtes
Problem deswegen zu überraschenderweise
haben ja ich meinte jetzt auch ganz
normale Menschen aus der Mitte der
Gesellschaft die zum Beispiel
Angestellte sind und deswegen haben sie
überraschenderweise ein FDP Politiker
eine steuersendung eingeladen weil wir
z.B auch ich der Meinung bin da sollte
man die Menschen entlasten ich glaube
auch dass ein Problem ist dass wir die
Unternehmen internationalen Vergleich
eher stark belasten also es gibt
Reformbedarf aber ich würde sagen es
gibt jetzt keinen kein ethisches
Desaster bei unserem Steuersystem
also eher bei 6,7 sind sie ja ja ich
finde die die 0 bis 10 Skala irgendwie
die schwierig die Frage ist ja in
welcher Hinsicht gerecht gerecht was
Verteilung angeht das Rahmenbedingungen
für Unternehmer wie Menschen haben noch
ein Gefühl dafür was gerecht was fair
ist also ich finde unser die kleine
mittleren Einkommen werden zu stark
belastet aber grundsätzlich Finanzierung
unseres Gemeinwesens ist im Grundsatz
fair bei 67 wie sieht das Frau Häuser
gerecht oder ungerecht von 0 bis 10 also
ich würde sagen wie sie eingangs auch
schon erwähnt haben wir wissen dass wir
Spitzen steuerreiter sind hier in
Deutschland wir haben die höchsten
Steuern und Abgaben was Arbeitnehmer und
Arbeitgeber betrifft da gibt es andere
Länder noch wie Japan und Malta die
höhere Steuern haben aber ansonsten sind
natürlich da schon schwer belastet und
ich bin schon auch dafür zu schauen dass
wir am Ende den Arbeitnehmern ich habe
ja tagtäglich mit unseren Mitarbeitern
zu tun die momentan mit der Krise mit
der Inflation Energiekrise zu kämpfen
haben explodierenden mieten dass wir am
Ende auch für Arbeitnehmer mehr Netto
brutto am Ende des Monats übrig also von
0 bis 10 wie gerecht ist das deutsche
Steuersystem
also wenn wir so bewerten dass wir sagen
was auch fakt ist dass starke Schultern
mehr tragen und das ist aktuell so das
heißt diejenigen die mehr verdienen
Zahlen auch mehr Steuern ist das in der
Sicht gerecht verteilt finde ich schon
außer das Thema das wir schauen müssen
dass mehr Netto vom Brutto übrig bleibt
am Ende okay er trauthötter wo sind sie
mit der bitte um kurze Antwort der
deutsche Staat schafft es einigermaßen
gut im internationalen Vergleich für
mehr Gerechtigkeit zu sorgen durch die
Steuern und die Ausgaben ich würde es
trotzdem eher bei einer fünf sehen oder
vielleicht noch ein bisschen drunter
weil tatsächlich die Vermögensverteilung
in Deutschland extrem ungleich ist
extrem ungerecht und das Steuersystem
weil es auch in den letzten 30 Jahren
geschwächt wurde nicht schafft da
tatsächlich für eine gewisse gleich dazu
tatsächlich sind die Vermögen in
Deutschland ähnlich umgerechnet verteilt
wie in Mexiko oder in Amerika
tatsächlich ähm ganz weit entfernt
voneinander unseren europäischen
Nachbarn und fast wieder so wie vorher
das muss
aus meiner Ansage vielleicht da wo sind
sie ich frag Frau Engel und ganz zum
Schluss nicht aus Unhöflichkeit sondern
weil ich sehr gespannt auf Ihre Antwort
bin wie gerecht für Kunden sind Antwort
ich glaube es gibt eine Dynamik die
tendenziell eher zum Schlechteren läuft
vor allem wenn wir auf die Steuern die
sie Ansprachen gehen Einkommen steuern
und vor allem auch die Konsum steuern
das sind ja die höchsten steuerposten
die wir haben in Deutschland und was man
da schon sehen kann ist das einerseits
alles richtig ist was sie sagen also de
factozahlen über 50% der Steuer
aufkommen zu kommen von den oberen zehn
Prozent der Einkommensteuer bezahlen und
bei der Mehrwertsteuer ist es so dass
überdurchschnittlich viel von Leuten mit
etwas weniger im Verhältnis zu dem
Einkommen bezahlt wird aber das da auch
die gut verdienen aber den Konsum
Steuern schon gut bezahlen das Problem
das wäre aber hatten in den vergangenen
Jahren ist und das ist eine dynamikfrage
1965 hat man den Spitzensteuersatz
bezahlt wenn man das 15-fache des
Durchschnittseinkommens hatte heute mit
dem 1,5 bis 1,9 fahren also das war fünf
Jahre
Fotos 1,5 bis 1,9 je nachdem welchen
Mittelwert man nimmt das heißt wir
zahlen viel zu früh sie bezahlen
Steuersatz Spitzensteuersatz wenn Sie
etwas über 60.000 Euro brutto verdienen
genau das ist viel Geld das ist aber das
was das heißt die Hälfte ist ungefähr
grob so jetzt kommt jetzt kommt das wo
ich widersprechen würde ihnen ich glaube
nichtsdestotrotz dass wir ein Problem
haben in der Verteilung weil natürlich
ist es so dass die Abgaben nicht nur aus
steuern bestehen sondern auch
Sozialabgaben die überdurchschnittlich
stark Menschen mit niedrigeren Einkommen
treffen und jetzt kommen wir wenn wir
die Steuersystem um Ihre Frage zu
beantworten wie gerecht ist es ist dann
kommen natürlich sofort dann kommen wir
natürlich eine Situation in der wir uns
zum einen Fragen müssen wenn wir das
ändern wollen wie finanzieren wir das
gegen und ich würde auch gern zwei
Punkte machen bevor ich eine Zahlen
nenne was die Gerechtigkeit des Systems
betrifft es hat nämlich noch zwei andere
Themen die dahin gehen wichtig sind wenn
man sich Konsum Besteuerung anguckt auch
da haben wir eine Situation dass wir
relativ viel Konsum es gibt ja nicht nur
die Mehrwertsteuer es gibt die Kerosin
aber es gibt die Pendlerpauschale es
gibt alle möglichen steuerermäßigen
gungen die klimaschädlich sind die nicht
besonders hilfreich sind also nur ein
Beispiel kerosinverbilligung 8
Milliarden
Mehrwertsteuer auf internationale Flüge
vier Milliarden Tankrabatt zig Millionen
mehrere Millionen in der letzten
Hilfsprogramm Frage und die Frage ist
warum gerecht warum ungerecht der
Einfluss organisierte Interessen auf das
Steuerrecht das unheimlich kompliziert
ist auch der Familienunternehmer ihres
Verbandes ist natürlich massiv womit wir
zum nächsten Punkt der Gerechtigkeit des
Steuersystems kommen ein Steuersystem
ist natürlich auch so gerecht wie
verständlich ist noch ist und wir haben
einen fast paar kompliziertes System in
dem Menschen die viel Geld und
Ressourcen einsetzen können sich die
gute Systeme untertan machen können und
ich bin sofort am Ende und der letzte
gerechtigkeitspunkt und dann kriegen sie
ihre Zahl ist aus meiner Sicht dass wir
natürlich in einer Welt leben in der wir
tatsächlich Arbeit sehr sehr hoch
besteuern
und unverdientes Vermögen ich nenne das
tatsächlich so Erbschaften nicht
besteuern ich bin maximal gegen 90%
Besteuerung aber mir ist nicht
ersichtlich warum man mir es nicht
ersichtlich warum jemand der arbeitet
der sich jeden Tag anstrengt mehr
bezahlen soll als jemand der etwas erbt
und deswegen meine Zahlen jetzt ne genau
genau das Problem ist nämlich auch in
diesem Kontext dass wir natürlich eine
Industrie haben ich meine es gibt ja Sie
können Erbschaftssteuer in Unternehmen
übertragen wenn Sie eine Banklizenz
beantragen dann beantragen Sie die
Banklizenz haben Family Office haben
noch eine Stiftung können ein zig
Milliarden Millionen schweres
Unternehmen steuerfrei übertragen und
wenn man sich mal anguckt wie viel human
Kapital das bindet wie viel unfassbar
kluge Menschen daran arbeiten dieses
System zu durchlöchern und zu bauen also
Steuer zu umgehen völlig richtig also
was wir in diesem Land schaffen könnten
wenn all diese klugen Menschen was
sinnvolles täglich ihre Zahl ich würde
sagen es kommt auf die Steuer an ich
würde aber sagen wir haben sicher mal
mit einer besseren Zahl angefangen
vielleicht acht ich bin nicht ganz so
pessimistisch ich würde vielleicht eine
sieben sechs im internationalen
Vergleich geben und vor allem glaube ich
auch nicht dass Unternehmen höher
besteuert werden sollten weil am Ende
werden immer Menschen besteuert und
nicht Unternehmen aber das ist sich ein
Thema für nachher okay sie dürfen sofort
der Vogel aber zunächst mal Marlene
Engelhorn die uns dankenswerterweise aus
Wien zugeschaltet ist freue mich sehr
dass das geklappt hat und ich habe sie
beobachtet sie haben mehrfach genickt
als Roman Blätter eben gesprochen hat
welche welche Zahl würden Sie denn im
deutschen Steuersystem geben wie gerecht
ist dieses deutsche Steuersystem
danke für die Einladung eine kleine
Klarstellung ich bin für textminderung
hier wir sagen nicht dass 90%
Besteuerung eine Forderung ist sondern
ich sage dass ich selbst mindestens
genau
das Steuersystem ist ungerecht weil
sonst hätten wir den Debatte hier nicht
hätten wir ein super gerechte
Steuersystem dann würde ich nicht dass
du ihn zugeschaltet werden um ihnen zu
erklären
dazu möchte ich aber jetzt auch noch
ausholen etwas dazu sagen nämlich eine
klitze kleine Kleinigkeit
Deutschland ist ein niedrigsteiland für
Vermögen und die Ausnahme in der
Erbschaftssteuer Kosten den Staat
jährlich Milliarden es kann doch nicht
sein dass ein Mensch der arbeiten geht
ganz normal Steuern zahlt und nie
gefragt wird ob er das gut findet oder
nicht oder ein Mensch der erbt immer
gefragt wird ist das eh okay so ganz ein
bisschen vielleicht manchmal total da
allein schon zeigt sich das eigentliche
Problem es geht hier um Macht und wie
sie verteilt wird und Steuerpolitik ist
nicht nur ein Mittel und ein Haushalt
aufzubessern sondern auch ein Mittel um
Macht die sich durch Vermögen bei
Privatpersonen und bei Eigentum
akkumuliert zu redemokratisieren und zu
resozialisieren und das ist eine
interessante bin ich gespannt was wir da
heute noch hören werden
deswegen nur mal ein Punkt ist wichtig
zu verstehen Frau Engelhorn deswegen
stelle ich das auch gerade nochmal klar
ich weiß genau jetzt sitzen ganz viele
Menschen zu Hause vom Fernseher und
sagen Texte besteuert mich bitte jetzt
und sagen da bitte hier ist meine
Kontonummer hier ist meine Bankleitzahl
jeden gewünschten Betrag einfach
überweisen und sie kennen mutmaßlich
auch die IBAN-Nummer des deutschen
Finanzamtes aber sie sagen darum geht es
nicht natürlich könnte ich das machen
aber mir geht es um etwas völlig anderes
worum geht's ihm dann
es wird oft so getan es wäre die
Besteuerung von Vermögen durch
unterschiedliche Steuerarten also
erbschafts-system reinspielt eine
öffentliche Angelegenheit das heißt ich
versuche nicht mein Privatproblem hier
zu lösen sondern mir geht es wie den
anderen bei Tags wieder auch darum und
wir sind ja auch Bündnispartner mit dem
netzwerksteuergerechtigkeit
aufzuzeigen dass diese öffentliche
Debatte zur gerechten Verteilung von
Vermögen an die Steuerdebatte geknüpft
ist und wie schafft man es einen
demokratischen transparenten
partizipativen inklusiven Diskurs
herzustellen um dafür zu sorgen dass wir
nicht künstlich einen Geldadel
Herstellen der besonders und
Familienunternehmen gebunden ist wie
können wir es so machen dass
Gerechtigkeit nicht das Maß derer ist
die davon profitieren sprich die reiche
darf sagen was gerecht ist sondern wie
kann man es so herstellen dass wir eine
Gerechtigkeit herstellen die eine
Selbstverständlichkeit von wir teilen
diese Vermögen so auf dass sie eben
nicht die Demokratie unterwandern dass
das die tatsächlich kann man das
hinkriegen das ist das sind Sache genau
was systemisches sozusagen wollte das
nur kurz klarstellen damit wir alle die
gleichen
Koordinaten kennen Frau Röser
Erbschaftssteuer Vermögenssteuer was
lösen solche Wörter bei Ihnen aus
wie vorhin schon erwähnt wir sind in
einem höchststeuerland wenn ich mir die
aktuelle Situation anschaue ich komme
selber aus dem Familienunternehmen das
100 Jahre alt ist meine u-großeltern
haben damals mit viel Schweiß und
arbeitest unter dem aufgebaut haben
gespart haben reinvestiert dass heute
dieses Unternehmen noch bestehen wie
viele Mitarbeiter haben sie machen sie
genau 50 Mitarbeiter wir sind wirklich
klassischer deutscher Mittelstand die
produzieren Beton Fertigteile Stahlbeton
Rohre also wirklich harte Arbeit auch
ähm intensiv der energieintensiv
natürlich wir haben momentan die
Energiekrise mit der wir zu kämpfen
haben aber auch viele andere Unternehmen
hier in Deutschland die ja sage ich mal
hausgemacht ist durch ja grüne Ideologie
getriebene Politik die wir hier leben
wir haben Inflation
natürlich ist natürlich auch die
Vorgängerregierung mit dran schuld aber
trotzdem haben wir die falschen
Weichenstellungen getroffen und
Entscheidungen getroffen in den letzten
Monaten wir haben Inflation wir haben
einen Konsum Rückgang und wir sind mit
wirklich vielen Herausforderungen
konfrontiert im deutschen Mittelstand
und wenn ich dann die Schreie nach
Vermögenssteuer Vermögensabgabe Erhöhung
der Erbschaftssteuer höhere dann würde
das für den deutschen Mittelstand
bedeuten dass er ausblutet weil wir
müssen wirklich unterscheiden zwischen
liquidem Vermögen von der Frau Engelhorn
spricht sie bekommt ein Vermögen vererbt
mit dem sie liquide entscheiden kann was
sie damit tut oder aber wir besprechen
und das ist bei mir und uns bei den
Familienunternehmen der Fall
betriebsgebundenes Vermögen das heißt es
in unseren Unternehmen gebunden das
liegt nicht auf den Konten ich kann
nicht einfach jetzt Millionen an Steuern
zahlen sondern das Vermögen muss in den
Unternehmen auch bleiben damit ich
weiter investieren kann damit ich den
Wohlstands und klimagerechten Umbau der
Wirtschaft hinbekomme digitale
Transformation dafür brauchen wir
Kapital und dafür muss das Kapital auch
erhalten bleiben
ökonomische Lösung für dieses Problem
also es ist völlig richtig was sie sagen
dass eine Substanz Besteuerung eines
Unternehmens also gegen eine
Vermögenssteuer weil ich glaube das sind
ein Eingriff in den laufenden
Produktionsprozess und auch die
administrativen Fragen die damit
einhergehen nicht richtig sind ich würde
trotzdem sagen eine Erbschaftssteuer auf
Unternehmen lässt sich
selbstverständlich bewerkstelligen also
man kann man kann je nachdem wie man das
ausgestalten würde also beispielsweise
gäbe es ja die Möglichkeit es gibt
verschiedene Vorschläge auch von
liberalen Ökonomen und von anderen es
gibt die Idee dass man sagt jemand der
ein Unternehmen erbt
der bezahlt die Steuern im Nachgang
nachrangig oder später im Prinzip
stundet er die Zeit die ab und darf ich
meinen Punkt machen und sie würden im
Kern natürlich dadurch weniger Gewinn
haben den serienvestieren können das ist
völlig richtig das ist mir auch bewusst
deswegen bin ich auch gegen die
Vermögenssteuer weil das den
Kapitalstock zu sagen greifen würde das
ändert überhaupt nichts dran dass wir
momentan 400 Milliarden Übergänge in
Erbschaften haben ungefähr die Hälfte
geht in den obersten zehn Prozent und
die werden mit 10 Milliarden Euro
besteuert das sind 2,5 % effektiv
interessiert und darauf werden gerade
mal 10 Milliarden ich möchte jetzt ganz
kurz noch um den Punkt zu machen und
zwar natürlich haben sie recht das ist
ein Eingriff in das Produktivvermögen
ein Problem ist das würde ich auch so
sehen und ich finde es auch falsch dass
man ein Unternehmen zerschlagen muss um
die Erbschaftssteuer bezahlen zu können
aber man könnte ohne Probleme einen
erbschaftssteuersatz eine Flat take
seines Szenen seines 15 seines 20
Prozent da kann man gucken es kann mehr
es kann weniger sein ich persönlich
glaube das ist sehr schwer ist zu
vermitteln warum jemand der arbeitet
mehr bezahlen sollte auch ihr
Eingangsstatement das andere davon
nichts nicht haben ist natürlich
quatscht weil man dadurch andere
entlasten kann die wenig haben und hohe
Abgaben zahlen und ich glaube dass man
machen könnte wäre natürlich dass man
über 10 20 Jahre den Start wegen den
Stellen Teilhaber an den Gewinnen
beteiligt und wer nicht in der Lage ist
diese dann wirklich relativ lächerliche
Erbschaftssteuer zu entrichten mein Gott
dann soll jemand das Unternehmen führen
der das kann aber darf ich mal ehrlich
darf ich mal kurz zurückkommen
ist typischer deutscher Mittelstand wir
reden ja wenn wir über
Familienunternehmen in Deutschland reden
und die die tatsächlich Einfluss auf
Politik nehmen über Unternehmen die
50.000 Mitarbeiter haben oder 5000 und
deutlich größer sind als ihr Unternehmen
und trotzdem sind sie in einer Hinsicht
ein typisches Mittelstandsunternehmen
sie haben nämlich das Geld im
Unternehmen
angespart tatsächlich um ein
Gewinnrücklage von 3 Millionen Euro auf
dem Konto liegen und das machen
tatsächlich sehr sehr viele deutsche
Mittelständler sie investieren nicht
mehr das kann man auch an den
makroökonomischen Zahlen sehen sondern
sie bauen Gewinnrücklagen auf um die
Sparkassen rauszuschmeißen um sich
völlig zu entschuldigen und haben
tatsächlich Milliarden auf dem Konto
liegen weil sie nicht mehr wissen wo sie
sind die Gewinne gehen nach oben die
netto Investition wir können froh sein
ganz kurz wir können froh sein dass wir
überhaupt die Möglichkeit hat in den
letzten Jahren Jahrzehnten im deutschen
Mittelstand so viel Eigenkapital
anzusparen wir hatten die letzten Jahre
eine massive corona-pandemie wir hatten
lockdowns staatlich verordnete der
lockdowns viele Betriebe mussten
schließen wir haben unsere Eigenkapital
Reserven viele Unternehmen aufgebraucht
wir können Glück haben
haben sie Staatshilfen bekommen viele
Familienunternehmer haben es gibt mal
natürlich Unternehmen die Staatshilfe in
Anspruch genommen haben wir persönlich
also wie bei uns im Unternehmen nicht
zum Glück wir mussten nicht darauf
zurückgreifen aber haben natürlich von
unseren Reserven gezerrt und ich glaube
das muss auch mal noch mal rausgestellt
werden dass es nicht nur heißt wir
horten das auf den Konten und dann
kaufen wir uns große Yachten davon wir
sparen an um später auch diese ganzen
Energie intensiven die ganze Klimakrise
müssen ja investieren in
Klimaschutzmaßnahmen sie haben es vorhin
angesprochen wir kommen aus ich komme
aus der
betonbau-industrie energieintensiv wir
müssen in neue Maschinen investieren
dafür brauchen wir Kapital und wie
wollen wir sonst die ganze Klima
finanzieren gerade 3 Millionen also ist
das eine habe ich im Internet ja
tatsächlich die Jahresabschlüsse von dem
Unternehmen sind ja öffentlich und dann
sieht man tatsächlich äh also
überhaupt und sich für Krisen
vorbereitet und Krisen resultiert ist zu
verstehen meine Frage wäre eher ist ist
das viel also drei Millionen scheint mir
jetzt für ein Unternehmen bei dem was
sie machen ist er jetzt nicht sozusagen
so dass man vor allem wenn ja der große
Investition eine große Maschine oder so
ansteht das habe ich noch mal ganz kurz
zurückkommen 10 Minuten nach nach
wenigen Minuten der Sendung schon sind
wir schon in der Frage wie man
Unternehmen mehr wegnehmen kann und die
ganze Ausgangsthese der Sendung Herr
lanz ist sie wollten abstrakt über
Steuern und wie fährt es unter
steuerungsrecht
werden
wie stark wir unternehmen was wegnehmen
können darf ich noch mal ganz kurz hoch
fliegen ich finde erstmal es ist kein
Wert an sich wenn wenn Menschen oder
Unternehmen besteuert werden sondern
unser Gemeinwesen muss ich für die
Aufgaben die wir wollen als Gesellschaft
gut finanzieren
in Deutschland mit den vielen
Familienunternehmen Personengesellschaft
die Frage was muss denn Steuersystem
leisten dass unser Gemeinwesen
ausreichend finanziert ist so wir kommen
von Jahr zu Jahr von Einnahme Rekord des
Staates zu einer amerikanischen Staates
dann ist die Frage wird das fair
verteilt ich würde sagen im Grundsatz ja
die starken Schultern tragen mehr aber
es gibt Ungerechtigkeiten im
Steuersystem aber in erster Linie die
die Herr Klettner eben genannt hat
nämlich dass wir kein und mittlerer
Einkommen immer stärker belasten in
Deutschland das sieht immer größeren
Anteil ertragen die sollten wir
entlassen und wir haben wenn ich auf die
Welt Lage Schauer haben wir ein Problem
weil ich sehe ein Land was bei allen
globalen Parametern Anteil der deutschen
Unternehmen und europäischen Unternehmen
an den größten Unternehmen der
weltgründungsquote
Investitionsquote immer weiter abfällt
und das ist ein riesen Problem und
gleichzeitig stellen wir fest dass die
immer ganz vorne sind bei der Steuerlast
der Unternehmen bei der effektiven
Steuerlast der Unternehmen und wir
diskutieren als allererstes darüber wie
wir mehr wegnehmen können das noch
irgendwie die ganz falsch
Herangehensweise sie sie machen das
jetzt sie verkürzen das auf einer Art
und Weise nicht okay ist doch wir die
Ausgangsfrage war doch eine andere die
ausbildungsfrage oder wie kann es sein
dass der Spitzensteuersatz so früh
beginnt ja genau
Aussage ich weiß nur wenn wir das ändern
wollen müssen wir doch an anderer Stelle
irgendwo mal Einnahmen Gegenüberstellung
generieren völlig statische Betrachtung
herans wir nehmen ja jedes Jahr immer
mehr Geld ein als Staat da können wir
uns die Frage stellen kann man einen da
muss man einen Teil von investieren das
ist Zukunft sozusagen
die Frage stellen ob wir vielleicht
durch gute Rahmenbedingungen für
Unternehmer und Unternehmerin dafür
sorgen dass wir Einnahmen generieren und
dann ein Stück weit die Frage stellen
was sind diese Rahmenbedingungen das ja
genau ich würde nur gerne ein bisschen
sortieren ich bin ganz auf ihrer Seite
und völlig undogmatisch unterwegs ja und
dem Punkt ja völlig wird trotzdem gerne
Frau Engelhorn fragen sie haben eben die
Argumentation und weil ich vorhin sagte
wir wollen ein bisschen grundsätzlicher
werden die einen wollen auf gar keinen
Fall mehr bezahlen die anderen sagen das
ist total ungerecht wir zahlen viel zu
viel
Erbschaftssteuer auf gar keinen Fall
dass der Untergang des Abendlandes
Vermögenssteuer genauso der
Industriestandort Deutschland ist in
Gefahr Arbeit wird auf der anderen Seite
viel zu hoch besteuert so geht's nicht
weiter sie kennen all diese Argumente
Freunde und ich weiß auch dass sie die
durchdringen und durchdacht haben wenn
sie diese Argumentation hören was
entgegen sind sie als jemand der sich
mit der Frage sollte man hohe Vermögen
auch deutlich höher besteuern so
intensiv beschäftigt
bei der Besteuerung von Vermögen geht es
erstmal darum sauber zu trennen von der
bestaunung von Arbeit weil wenn wir
anfangen zu vermischen und direkt
reingehen in was spitzenverdienerinnen
nicht alles abgeben dann vermischen wir
die Debatte dann vermischen wir die
Begrifflichkeiten ich kann über
Einkommen nicht sprechen ich will
Übereinkommen nicht sprechen ich möchte
über vermögensbezogene Steuern sprechen
das Ding bei Vermögen ist ja es geht nur
um die Frage von wie wichtig es um damit
ich dann am Ende die Steuer nicht zahle
eine Art von Privileg die sich sonst
kein Mensch leisten kann und zwar
buchstäblich Vermögen bedeutet Macht
Vermögen ist immer am Ende mit einer
Person verknüpft es kann doch nicht sein
dass wir erlauben dass seine Handvoll
Menschen weil wen betrifft diese
Erbschaftssteuer effektiv wirklich wenn
es dann im hochvermögen geht maximal 5%
der Bevölkerung es ist ein absolutes
Nischen unterliegenden Thema wie kann es
sein dass diese Menschen einerseits bei
der Erbschaftssteuer von der letzten
ordentlich mit erwischen das ist auch
gut dokumentiert bei der zdf-dok oder
Chef Lobbys der Stiftung
Familienunternehmen meint das sei
irgendwie das erfolgreichste Politik
eingreift ging das ich habe das Zitat
leider nicht perfekt im Kopf auf jeden
Fall war klar zu sehen die brüsten sich
auf damit das mitzuschreiben dass da
immer mehr ausnahmen hineingebastelt
werden und was passiert am Ende die
immer selben Familien sind in der
Machtposition und entscheiden darüber
wie Geld und Vermögen verteilt wird wie
die Unternehmenslandschaft ausschaut
welche Priorität bestimmte Krisen haben
oder nicht wer am Ende wo wie draus
schaut macht konzentriert sich
maßgeblichen Vermögen Besteuerung ist
eine Art und Weise sich diesem Diskurs
zu nähern und zu sagen okay wenn wir
macht in Vermögen bündeln dann müssen
wir auch schauen ist es denn
demokratisch legitim dass manche
Menschen nur aufgrund ihrer Familie also
nur aufgrund des Nachnamens macht im
kleinen Finger haben die bei anderen
Menschen in in großer Stimmenanzahl
niemals da wäre also es ist wirklich die
Demokratie Frage im Kern Politik geht
ins Herz der Demokratie es ist bei
Finanzpolitik ja auch das ist in Zahlen
gegossene Gesellschaftspolitik wieso ist
es in Ordnung dass Ausnahmen bei
Vermögen gemacht werden immer wenn zum
Besteuerung geht und bei allen anderen
Steuerarten nicht da ist es
selbstverständlich und kein Mensch der
arbeiten geht und regulär seine
Einkommensteuer bezahlten jetzt mache
ich selber den Schwenk weil ich diese
Gegenüberstellung so wichtig ist wichtig
genau gefragt finden Sie das eigentlich
gut wie ihre Arbeit so besteuert wird
das ist eine Frage gestellt man nur
vermögenden Menschen weil man denen auch
unterstellt dass sie die Macht und die
Entscheidungsgewalt haben mitzureden
darüber wie Sie gerne besteuert werden
wollen oder wie nicht Umverteilung
findet statt de facto momentan von unten
nach oben und das muss echt nicht sein
und eine kleine Korrektur von der
Kollegen vorher bearbeitet aber bei
Vermögen ist es ein niedrigste Land